they have been providing help to those
in need in our community for 80 years
and counting we're talking about
catholic charities of southern nevada
the sponsors of this segment and joining
us to tell us more about the
organization is senior vp and chief
operating officer steve schmidt hello
steve how are you
good afternoon thank you so much for
having me on it is a pleasure tell us a
little bit about catholic charities what
do you do
well like you said since 1941 as you
mentioned 80 years hard to believe
there's not many things 80 years old in
las vegas but catholic charities of
southern nevada has served those in need
the most vulnerable in the las vegas
valley and through the generosity of our
many foundations grants and many
individual donors our 16 programs and
services have provided support to more
than 4 000 people each and every day i
know that you guys have been doing so
much in the community but you've also
been doing a campus renovation can you
tell me a little bit about that
as you just said we we are undergoing a
major renovation of our eight acre
campus on north las vegas boulevard
where we have been located for over 20
years some people may remember this was
the former vegas village site uh we
recently celebrated the reopening of our
dining hall where we welcome back not
only the nearly 500 guests that we serve
there every day but also volunteers i
know you guys were there on thanksgiving
and christmas to film some of those
events
and now we're currently in the process
of renovating our emergency night
shelter which exists to help 400 adult
homeless men every night of the year and
give them a place to shower and sleep
and we hope to complete this phase in
late spring early summer let's talk a
little bit about that shelter it
how does it help
vulnerable people get back on their feet
our shelter much like the dining hall is
there to serve a fundamental human need
that is food in our and our dining room
and pantry and shelter a place to sleep
but like all our services this isn't a
final destination but a stop along the
way to recovery uh throughout all our
services whether it's our pantry dining
room or shelter we create a safe and
welcoming environment where case
managers who are here at all hours can
get in touch with our clients directly
assess their situation and help them
navigate whatever situation they're in
put them in touch with needed services
mental or behavioral health all with the
goal to get them back on their feet and
become self-sustainable we do that
through all our programs like renewing
hope which helps them with job training
and life skills as well as our housing
navigation center which can help them
get housing or even something as simple
as a bus ticket home that i love that
that it is not a final destination and
you are there just to help them get back
where they need to be now if people want
to help
how do they do that do they where do
they donate
so if your easiest way is to go to our
website we have a number of volunteer
opportunities available including
helping out in our food pantry or
serving our community meal but the most
impactful are monetary donations where
89 cents of every dollar goes directly
to programs and services which helps us
sustain our operations throughout the
year and serve those most in need again
please visit catholiccharities.com to
find out all the ways you can help thank
you for all that you and everyone at
catholic charities for what you do it's
amazing and every donation helps thank
you for your time catholic charities of
southern nevada help them sustain their
operations throughout the year and serve
those in need again for those who can
give at this time please visit
catholiccharities.com or call them at
702-385-2662
kendall